hallo mein name ist luca und meine damen
und herren das ist jule herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem weiteren
video der gugl play game on kampagne
wohl und ich verschiedene spiele spielen
werden und uns in diesen spielen in
challenges betteln werden das heutige
spiel ist tims mobile challenge die wir
uns heute gesetzt haben seht ihr hier
schon eingeblendet das ist nämlich die
elena löhrer
die ist beruflich lehrer wie ist
unsozial und genau die elena ist unsere
channel unsere challenge heute ist dass
wir uns gegenseitig ein zimmer erstellen
lassen zusätzlich die leute mit so viel
elan und freude die aufnahme denn juli
was machen wir heute richtig wir stellen
uns gegenseitig in sims das heißt ich
fange jetzt direkt an und erstelle jetzt
hier die jule dh nachnamen hörer
charakterlichen lassen jule löhrer so
siehst du aus also direkt fällig also
beim kopf würde ich sagen wenn ich mir
das so anschaue du hast du hast so einen
kopf
seine augen sind nicht so nach außen
geneigt sondern eher von der form her so
würde ich sagen was das
augen
juli
die stupsnase deswegen nase würde ich so
eine empfehle hier
das ist schon 11 bitte haben sie halt
nicht so richtig doch da aber das passt
auch nicht so richtig dass ihr passt
doch das passt schuhe trägt juli
natürlich immer die falschen sneaker
hier deswegen nehme die man in grün hier
2000 jahre später freunde die jule haben
wir fertig erstellt die sieht so aus
also
wir müssen jetzt erst mal das tutorial
spielen bei jule gerade hier ein neues
gebäude eingezogen ist sie muss jetzt
erst mal aufräumen hier schon noch wie
sofa auf räume juli machst du das hier
auch kummer mit schwung die plane
entfernen da ist ein lifestyle
verbessere dann möchte er auch
schlafzimmer oder auf sparte zumal
konzentrieren schlafzimmer das passt zu
dir wir haben versucht audi hat die
bella grube machte party also wir reisen
jetzt mit der jule löhrer hier in
parkgelände und u
das café freigeschaltet
hier wurde
richtig lecker macht mir dieses wissen
ob wir schon so ne du bist so gut in
diesem spiel
[Musik]
so freuen wenn jetzt gerade die ganze
zeit gespielt die ableger hat eine
kleine teilnetz eingeblendet gesehen
julia ordentlich kaffee gekocht
wir haben ordentlich aufgeräumt mit
kollegen gefaulenzt in unserem café und
jetzt fügen wir einen mitbewohner zu
unserem haushalt hinzu und das wird jude
jetzt übernehmen
die wird nun nämlich mich als zum
charakter erstellen und hier sieht doch
schon ganz gut aus
um nicht länger mit noch mal wir sind
noch gar nicht verheiratet
ja aber dann im herzen durch den bonner
an deinen kopf schmeißen
ziemlich perfekt oder das event wo meine
augen aussehen
deine augen ist es schon schöner er grün
ist aber viel seltener als blau was mit
meiner nase als stabil
[Musik]
hey du bist gar nicht
die guckt mich immer an machte haye fast
2000 jahre später ja freuen uns wieder
einige zeit vergangen
die schule hat sich ordentlich mühe
gegeben und das ist dabei rausgekommen
also das bin ich ihr seht ihr jetzt noch
einmal den film den ich für julia
erstellt habe und dem slim den juden für
mich erstellt hat eingeblendet das heißt
sie können jetzt morgen in die
kommentare schreiben wer sage ich mal
ja den anderen besser getroffen hat wer
diese challenge eurer meinung nach
gewonnen hat an der stelle würden wir
dieses ems mobile challenge ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ihr findet einen link zu dem
spiel und in der beschreibung und auch
einen link zu den besten google place
tor spielen 2018 wir befinden uns jetzt
hier auch in der endart freunde findet
hier einen sims mobile logo eingeblendet
wenn ihr darauf könnt ihr euch das spiel
selber runter laden selbst man spielen
wenn es euch gefallen hat und ihr findet
ihr auch noch ein anderes video von mir
eingeblendet und zwar die asphalt
challenge tae yun und ich vor einiger
zeit schon gemacht haben
checkt das gern mal ab